pour savoir vraiment qui vous êtes on va
faire une interview
simon bouge pas avant lundi
bien alors est ce que vous êtes mytho
oui skeezo oui part à l'euro oui un peu
moins mais oui bazot
non pas trop so do we sado non plus
exhibo un peu oui géronto pas du tout
pédo non sens quand même que
n'a pas non parce que c'est pas les
galères mais a parlé de massenet sukala
fétiche oh non ça va adamo non gayssot
oui oui vous êtes tous finalement non
mais sérieusement non vous avez tous les
vices en fait gérante au sol géronto il
à ne pas les vieilles j'en ai marre
d'eau ouais non mais lévis où la cité
d'ailleurs dans le dans le bouquin que
vous avez sorti sur wild lévis où la
perversité c'est en fait où elle
décrivait que la perversité c'était un
mythe inventé par les bonnes gens pour
expliquer l'étrange attraits de certains
autres la perversité lévis je pense que
c'est une façon de de passer de belles
journées quoi c'est pas forcément
désagréable
je suis sûr que si on perd on est tous à
ce questionnaire y auraient chacun de
nous ré davis comme ça je sais pas je
voulais pas fier le genre julia qui peut
dire qu'il n'ya aucun vide sans vie
d'andré et qui peut dire que cet avis
oui